è un grande piacere è un contesto molto
diverso rispetto a quelle delle Call
classiche e quindi cercherò in questi
pochi minuti anche di avere un
atteggiamento un po' Entertainment di
alleggerire i toni non per banalizzare
l'argomento ma per trasmettere in modo
appunto più teatrale perché comunque ho
abbastanza esperienza dal punto di vista
del Public speaking però le volte in cui
sono stato solo sul palco in un teatro
si possono contare veramente sulle dita
della mano forse è l'unica volta almeno
che mi ricordo per dare anche un
ulteriore indicazione di chi sono io ho
insegnato anche in università Cattolica
e strumenti di intelligenza artificiale
per le previsioni finanziarie è ancora
adesso visto che il tempo ne ho
moltissimo a disposizione sono anche
strategie
degli operatori finanziari e ovviamente
il mio grande interesse lavorativo e
anche personale è proprio la finanza
sostenibile siccome
teorie della comunicazione del
trasferimento dei concetti mi hanno
sempre spiegato quando era a Londra
perché la mia cultura è fondamentalmente
quella anglosassone quella dei derivati
può essere sintetizzata in solo tre
grandi concetti che possono essere
trasferiti mi hanno insegnato che
bisogna essere bravi a capire quali sono
gli obiettivi da raggiungere come farlo
e poi essere sicuri che gli obiettivi
sono stati raggiunti io quindi agisco
direttamente a cuore aperto in modo
molto sincero io tre obiettivi Oggi
primo farvi capire come è avvenuta in
questa prima fase la consapevolezza del
mondo finanziario del problema climatico
la seconda che cos'è Finanza sostenibile
ovviamente cercherò di essere
divulgativo io ho un modo di esposizione
che è lineare ma tende al cazzeggio
quindi spero comunque attraverso alcune
curve di andare diritto nella strada
tanto che facevo non dico disperare i
ragazzi ma tutte le volte che provavamo
provavamo sempre e veniva una versione
diversa questa ne sarà un'altra ancora
La terza è capire il futuro non solo del
clima della finanza sostenibile Per
quanto riguarda il primo punto come io
personalmente sono stato resodotto del
problema di Finanza sostenibile Al di là
del fatto che io lavoravo nella Finanza
pura all'interno di un ciclo di
startupping che la mia banca garantisce
al dipendente che vogliono proporre
qualcosa di nuovo
preparai una startup che si occupava di
Finanza sostenibile di Advisory cinque
anni fa 5 anni fa è una era geologica
Per quanto riguarda questi temi e questa
startup molto ben definita molto ben
disegnata fu gloriosamente
magnificamente splendidamente bocciata
andò malissimo tanto che ci Rimasi male
Non capisco perché mi hanno messo in
questo progetto dell'ONU che era uno dei
primi che partiva sul clima salvo poi
dopo una settimana ricevere la proposta
di diventare responsabile del marketing
strategico e poi occuparmi di questi
temi Ma il primo episodio che ci ha
fatto capire quanto importante fosse la
questione quanto fossimo in negazione
noi in inglese in denari del tema fu
quando avevamo riunito un guru
dell'ambientalismo che si è presentato
da noi voi immaginate da una parte
questi bankers tutti così tutti con
cravattati tutti belli anche arrabbiati
convinti no quanto è il nastro d'oro sta
scendendo arriva questo ambientalista
bermudoni color cachi Voi sapete che il
color cachi Tra l'altro uno dei
preferiti degli scrittori dicono tutti
al vestito color cachi Non so perché non
so se avete anche voi intuito questo
aspetto però color cachi fatto la scarpa
già inizierò a avere qualche sospetto
perché erano tutte quelle oggetto dire
Selling no Quindi quelle non voglio dire
nomi o Marche No però erano abbastanza
di valore
quindi sembrava un po' Bob Marley però
con l'ingaggio più vicino ai Coldplay no
si siede e questo romanesco che almeno
all'inizio tratteggio
che non farò per tutta la parte della
sua spiegazione ci disse voi
ciò sapete che durante la vita
milionaria da terra
ci sono state cinque dico cinque
estinzioni di massa delle specie viventi
a quel punto il Gesù apotropaico no
scaramantico della platea di banchieri
iniziava a controllare il materiale del
tavolo se fosse ferro o meno e
ovviamente non è elegantissimo a dire in
molti hanno cercato se avevano le chiavi
a un portafoglio in tasca No Perché in
effetti ci fu un impatto molto forte
proseguì dicendo
Near triasco adesso ritorno in italiano
insomma Nel triassico Giurassico 200
milioni di anni fa
si estinse
l'84% Delle specie viventi a seguito
dell'innalzamento della temperatura di
5°c
non abbiamo avuto la prontezza di
rispondere e ci disse 150 mila anni ok
con l'accordo di Parigi 2015 stiamo
cercando di contenere innalzamento di un
grado e mezzo probabilmente andremo
anche verso i due gradi della domenica
del Global warming però stiamo parlando
di 200 anni Chi è Milanese come me ha
superato i 50 anni sa che la nebbia è
sparita è la prima volta nel mondo che
il cambiamento climatico ha un orizzonte
ristretto a una generazione o due
generazioni quindi primo cambiamento
climatico problema serio oggettivo chi
non lo si confronta con questa onestà
intellettuale è un terrapiattista almeno
dal mio punto di vista cioè va verso Per
posizioni negazionisti estreme prima
cosa perché la finanza
voi immaginate che il mondo debba
convertirsi verso la transizione in
questo momento parliamo soprattutto
della equila energetica Ma la s sociale
è altrettanto importante ci focalizziamo
soprattutto sulla e che il mondo debba
iniziare a vivere e produrre consumare
senza produrre CO2 come prima attraverso
un processo di convergenza è
difficilissimo è complesso ma
soprattutto richiede una quantità enorme
di capitali ogni organizzazione
sovranazionale ne stima
per esempio 2030 l'ocse ma ce ne sono
tantissime la Bay parliamo di 3000 4000
miliardi di dollari nell'orizzonte di 20
30 40 anni per convertire processi
produttivi lo dico in modo molto
generico la finanza trova una ragion
d'essere in una Comunanza di obiettivi
cercando di veicolare gli strumenti a
disposizione verso
decarbonizzazione primo aspetto
importante di quantità adesso nella
cosiddetta Finanza sostenibile e faccio
una parentesi sostenibile perché è un
aggettivo che si usa ma in realtà la
finanza ha già perso l'aggettivo e
diventa Finanza turco perché già
un'obbligazione su 4 è Green un prestito
su 5
e Green Ciò significa quindi che già
Esistono dei framework delle logiche
attraverso quali si raccolgono
attraverso obbligazioni o attraverso
strumenti di prestito fondi per
destinazioni d'uso che abbiano dei
progetti di decarbonizzazione che siano
progetti di economia circolare che siano
progetti di rinnovabili di qualsiasi
tipo che però porti a una riduzione
della CO2 Quindi questo è un aspetto
importante e il settore pubblico da
impulso da garanzie Ma da solo non ce la
può fare la cittadinanza fa il lavoro
della finanza ma in questo modo viene
impiegata a scopi di profitto ma di
carattere Ovviamente con lo sfondo più
socialmente ambientalmente accettabile
la finanza sostenibile non è una Finanza
agevolata non viene fatta a tassi
migliori migliorare il mondo non
permette di prendere a prestito o di
avere dei rendimenti necessariamente
migliori Non è detto Poi vediamo appena
dopo questa indicazione qualcosa di
leggermente diverso l'esempio classico è
di una discussione che io ho avuto con
un cliente che mi diceva benissimo Vuoi
che io faccia il mio prodotto Green
Dammi fondi non dico a fondo perduto ma
ha un tasso di interesse estremamente
conveniente
E io gli ho risposto Guarda che il tuo
problema non è avere adesso i tassi
bassi per diventare Green è che se tu
non diventi Green fra un anno due anni
tu andrai fuori mercato e avrai tasse
molto più alti farei fatica a trovare
chi ti dà soldi Se non hai questa
impostazione verso la decarbonizzazione
questa ha portato Tra l'altro a due
considerazioni molto importanti che vi
voglio trasferire primo secondo uno
studio che noi abbiamo fatto si può dire
con la Bocconi qui
Io sono un bocconiano eh
però l'ho detto verso la metà di
internet così A me non mi votate subito
allora con la bocca ne abbiamo fatto
questo studio che ha evidenziato che i
modelli di produzione e di consumo
circolare hanno un effetto
importantissimo riducono il rischio di
default di fallimento dell'azienda
attenzione Questo è un passaggio
fondamentale quindi l'ambientalismo in
sé non è un valore solo
legato a quello che stiamo
rappresentando Ma è un valore anche
economico come è stato detto nel primo
intervento se noi fossimo stati tutti
compliant e CO2 friendly fossimo stati
tutti rinnovabili non ci sarebbe stata
la guerra Probabilmente perché avevamo
autonomia energetica e anche sicurezza
energetica no Questo per capire che
comunque le banche hanno tutto
l'interesse la finanza ad avere
all'interno del proprio portafoglio
aziende che sono orientate a questo
percorso di deca informazioni e
addirittura lo favoriscono attraverso
dei fondi indicati Noi abbiamo 8
miliardi Direttamente collegati
all'economia circolare 80 del prossimo
obiettivo di piano Orizzonte di piano
proprio dedicati al finanziamento delle
attività Green
E questo perché abbiamo avuto l'adesione
al ne-0 banchina Alliance che è una
Alleanza internazionale
che ha come obiettivo al 2050 che
nessuna di queste banche che
rappresentano circa 80 per cento dei
prestiti che queste banche danno al
sistema A livello mondiale
abbiano nei portafoglio aziende che non
emettono CO2 zero è proprio
stesso succede per gli asset manager
stesso Succede Per quanto riguarda
l'insurance però questo è
importantissimo perché chi vuole
chiedere credito trova già un sistema
che è reticente a dare credito se queste
organizzazioni non intraprendono non
hanno un percorso di transizione che la
dico in modo semplice poi ci sono dei
dettagli tecnici che però in questo
momento io vorrei omettere ovviamente il
problema è particolarmente complicato lo
abbiamo visto è stato accennato
sull’outcam un po' deludente di Coop 27
perché voi sapete bene che l'8% della
CO2 viene messa da noi in Europa e siamo
il continente più avanti nella cultura
nella consapevolezza e anche nella
regolamentazione su questi temi
ambientali avete sentito parlare della
tassonomia Europea da questo punto di
vista ma 9/3 della CO2 vengono messi da
Stati Uniti che ha sterzato dopo biden A
dire il vero verso una direzione
virtuosa ma Cina e India
però non è una regolamentazione
legislativa o finanziaria il problema
dell'ambiente non si nasconde sotto il
tappeto perché se noi non inquiniamo e
andiamo a zero riduciamo dell'8% delle
missioni Ma se qualcuno aumenta dell'8%
ne facciamo uno sforzo culturalmente
fondamentale necessario da driver ma non
è sufficiente ecco dunque perché la
questione deve espandersi anche con
queste alleanze bancarie a livello
internazionale
Io vorrei fare una chiusura diciamo di
tutti questi temi abbastanza complicati
con un altro aspetto la valutazione
dell'azienda attualmente dove lavoro ma
nella maggior parte degli istituti tiene
conto di un Identikit questo che si
chiama energia sestment cioè di una
valutazione dell'azienda anche in
termini ambientali sociali e di
governance quindi Ogni azienda ha già un
suo Rating che non è solo quindi merito
di credito finanziario Ma anche in
merito di credito di carattere
ambientale è chiaro che devono essere
costruiti gli standard e ci vorrà tempo
affinché questo accada perché c'è una
storia relativa che non può essere
costruita come quella della storia
dell'analisi di bilancio che viene da
decenni di consolidamento Ma è una via
obbligata che in questo momento non
risparmia nessun settore nessuna
geografia
nessuna dimensione aziendale tutti sono
e coinvolte all'interno di questa
valutazione influirà anche sul merito
creditizio per chiudere come vedete la e
Voi vedete la s all'interno di questa
parte s ovviamente c'è la definizione
ridefinizione di Qual è il livello
giusto di profitto No è un tema
particolarmente Vasto Non è una
questione solo redistributiva ma per
essere consapevolmente responsabile dal
punto di vista ambientale ci deve essere
anche una valutazione inserita
all'interno dell'azienda che poi orienti
anche le sue valutazioni in termini di
andamento azionari di redditività però
all'interno della S io vedo Qui molti
giovani
devo dire che la politica relativa allo
sviluppo di talento dei giovani che sono
fondamentali saranno fondamentali è
stato detto non voglio ripetermi il
primo intervento proprio per la Maggiore
consapevolezza che hanno su questi temi
dovranno avere il l'onere e di portare
avanti le grandi sfide che noi abbiamo
iniziato io spero di avere una
generazione che il signor come me devono
allevare sostenere coccolare stimolare
Ma che poi va nella responsabilità
vostra nella forza propositiva che
avrete per portare i risultati che
dovranno essere trasferiti nel corso del
tempo perché per la prima storia durante
quella del mondo non si parla più di
sopravvivenza diciamo Della generazione
successiva ma della specie umana nel
complesso Quindi io vi do a voi
l'augurio che ho ricevuto all'inizio
della mia attività lavorativa da un mega
Trader inglese Voi sapete quelli un po'
su queste camicie sempre Violette non so
se voi sapete avevano sempre questa
capacità di essere un po'
orientate al consumo di birra ma insomma
niente di
legale che mi dissero una volta
Ricordati che nella tua vita dovrai
essere
be good
be flexibles
alla parola fortuna io mi irrigidii come
io mi sono laureato
Cosa c'entra la fortuna e lui mi disse
Sì perché ti renderai conto e questo è
un concetto che ti trasferisco a voi che
per essere
fortunati e per meritarsela bisogna
essere bravi e flessibili Quindi io
Auguro a voi tutto il bene possibile per
il vostro e il nostro futuro Grazie e
arrivederci
[Applauso]